remember when its software showed off  that generic cover art for the upcoming  doom reboot well now you can vote for  something much better i'm tony and this  gamespot news update is hella cool  alright that pun sounded a lot better in  my head the cover art will be reversible  and you have two choices for the  alternative look the first one looks  like a pretty wicked metal album cover  sporting a demon head and a pentagram  the second looks very much like the  original art from 1993 with our favorite  space marine taking on a horde of  monsters you can vote for your favorite  through the official doom Twitter  account but only for the next four days  stoom hits ps4 xbox one and pc on May  thirteenth we're still waiting to hear  about that promised beta 2 so stay tuned  to gamespot for more information and for  all the doom news you need you're  already in the right place  you